this is a production of cornell
university
um
now if i did this the wrong way you
might say i did because i listened to
frank rossi when i said i was giving
this seminar and frank said kind of you
know not a lot of data you know put a
few jokes in there so i'm following his
advice so if it goes awry don't blame me
blame him um basically what i was going
to do is really just give a good
overview of the types of data that go
into climate research and working with
dave and the number of people here at
allen you know that that always comes up
where are we getting this data from you
know the the observed data the data from
the past the current data that we use
and then more importantly as we move on
to it the data we're going to use in the
future so that's kind of a little bit of
background
about my slide
and then just kind of going over the
contents
really here that
the middle part is going to be kind of
short changed but the first part and the
last part is where i'm going to focus
most of my effort
and i'm focusing on the first part in
this kind of intriguing bullet here
climate gate anyone know the whole
scandal of emails in the research lab in
east anglia and things like that yeah
i'm going to try to shed a little bit of
light on that and really the bottom line
and all of that is you know climate data
have been collected for a number of
years hundreds of years 100 years at
least
but never with the intent of monitoring
climate change so it's basically data
set that's out there it's been used for
other purposes had its roots pretty much
in agriculture and it's only now
recently that we've been using these
data to to monitor climate change and
that has some implications to it and
hopefully i'll i'll bring that out in
some of my talk
and then really in the end what we have
to boil down to is we're trying to
project these climate parameters into
the future 100 years into the future how
can we go about doing that and more
importantly how can we do go about doing
that at the scale that is just right
most of the models we operate on are
these big global
climate models that have kind of one
observation for an area about the size
of new york
but yet we're interested in can we will
be able to grow grapes in the finger
lakes um in 2100 or will this crop do
well in new york and so forth and so on
so there it's a matter of getting the
size just right
really the whole backbone of the
climate network observed climate network
in the united states is something that's
called the historical climatology
network
and i'm going to use the us as an
example but this is a good example for
pretty much anywhere else in the world
where there is an extensive set of
observed meteorological data going back
100 years so mostly europe same thing in
china and russia really these types of
issues and things are things that come
up in all of the networks for the u.s
there are approx little over a thousand
stations in this network to cover the
size of the u.s
the resolution of these data is
primarily daily so not hourly data
things like that daily and really it's
measuring three things the daily maximum
temperature the daily minimum
temperature and how much rainfall the
daily precipitation so that's really the
100 year record we're really confined to
these measurements
many stations almost all of them have
50-year records some have more than 100
years records and like i said before
never intended to really track climate
change and kind of just to put this into
perspective
um you know the historical climate
network is pretty much the cream of the
cream of these stations if we look at
any old station there's about today
about six thousand eight thousand
somewhere in there depending on where we
are stations that actually record these
observations
if i use a rain gauge as an example if i
took every rain gauge that was
operational in the united states today
and put them rim to rim okay anyone want
to venture a guess how big of an area
that would cover
go ahead tom rhode island
no not run island
better soccer square
neil is closer a tennis court
okay we take every rain gauge in the u.s
put them room to rim we got a tennis
court so that kind of gives you an idea
of what we're dealing with here to
measure
climate change or anything on a national
scale
there's this distribution of these
stations pretty much have good coverage
across the country kind of sparse in
some of the areas you would expect them
to be sparse but overall a pretty good
coverage
this is what a typical state this is
kind of what a typical station looks
like this is the game farm road station
and really a few extra instruments here
but the main ones are this rain gauge
here with a windshield around it and two
temperature sensors and we'll talk about
that a little bit more later the primary
sensor is this one right here which is
called the max min temperature sensor
um
the one thing about the u.s historical
climate network is it's citizen science
in action it's been citizen science
forever these things are pretty much in
people's backyards okay so this is an
example of a station i don't know which
one it is um in the historical climate
network the rain gauge is out of the the
frame but here's the mmts
the network also expands to some um
airport stations so here's the
temperature center of binghamton which
is part of this but for the most part
these are volunteer networks
the weather service is supplying the
instrumentation but the volunteer is
supplying manpower
there are some bad apples and this is
really the crux of climate gate so
here's an example of an mmts that's kind
of in some bushes and right by a big
asphalt parking lot not the best
exposure for measuring temperature
here's an even worse exposure for
measuring temperature that's a burn
barrel i don't know what that looks like
and there's a fair number of these again
a really bad exposure here this is the
temperature sensor up there so i mean
you don't need to be a climatologist to
figure out that these are not good
locations for measuring temperature
however
these few bad apples i mean these are
just the bad examples that i picked out
here what i want to say is they don't
spoil a bunch so if we actually go out
and look at these stations okay and it
was kind of it's kind of
you know
the the sad part about it is when these
stations were selected to be in the us
climate network probably about 30 years
ago 20 years ago nobody went out and
looked at them they looked at the length
of record they looked at the amount of
missing data they never looked at the
sites so that's why these bad apples
are in the bunch but when we look at
this basically the blue line is a
temperature trend over the last
50 or so years
from
the good stations
the bass stations the cream of the crops
the ithacas the the stations that are in
nice pristine environments
the red line is all of the stations so
if we take all of the stations the bad
apples and all and what we can see is
that really those few add bad apples
make some difference in the exact
numbers but overall if we're looking at
the trend we have the same pretty much
magnitude and pattern of trend through
time okay so when
these scientists from east anglia
were criticized for taking some data out
of their analyses
what they were actually doing
was
separating out the bad apples that occur
not only here but across the globe i
could have taken examples of stations
like this from any country
again they are the they are the
exceptions rather than the world
the data are processed in a number of
different ways and they're processed to
remove
non-climatic things that creep into them
so pretty much the easiest things are
things like quality control and missing
data and urbanization basically here a
very simple adjustment on the raw data
to adjust for population so something
like a growing city where population is
changing gets adjusted that warming due
to urbanization is removed from the data
and again quality control is really my
wall grade sign it's not 501 so things
like that and i mean this is probably a
common error keeping in mind up until
very recently these things were keyed in
from paper form so the observer went out
to the station wrote down a number sent
in his form or her form at the end of
the month and somebody digitized these
so it's very easy that you know 50.1 got
keyed in as 50 or 501.
the stations are adjusted for
relocations
um
this is the current ithaca station
this is the ithaca station in 1930.
that is the temperature shelter
anyone know what building that is
that's robert hall so the roof of
roberts hall was the official
observation site in the 1930s um a bunch
of other stuff up here was it really
warm back then it was if you look at the
ithaca record the record highs in ithaca
are in the 1930s why it's a black roof
on the top of ramen
okay
a lot a lot different here we're about
at the same level now so kind of if you
want to fact you know think of climate
change that way the roof of roberts hall
and gamefront road are about even
actually back here ithaca was an
official weather service station there
was a weather bureau office in roberts
hall and just as a this thing up here is
actually the signal flag so they they
throw up a flag you know you see a
hurricane flag or something like that
flying there used to be one of those on
the roof of robert's hall
um
the data are adjusted for a change in
instrumentation
basically prior to the mid 1980s the
temperatures were taken by a maximum
minimum thermometer liquid and glass
enclosed in the stevenson screen
in the mid 1980s most of the stations
not all
moved on to an electric sensor here
which is a thermal couple inside the
mmts so these are the two basically for
the last 100 years these are the only
two types of instruments that you can
use
the data are also adjusted for
observation time
these are once a day observations of
maximum minimum temperature taken by
volunteers
so i'm an early riser and for me it
might be easier to take my observation
in the morning before i come into work
so if i were doing that and this is my
example of a morning observation if i
was coming in and say i took my
observation at seven am
okay so if i took my observation at
seven am on this morning i would be
looking at the lowest temperature in
this 24-hour period and it just so
happened to occur right when i took the
observation okay so this value is a
little bit colder than that value so
that's my min
i reset my thermometer can only go to
the minimum temperature i can't make it
any more colder or any more warmer then
i come back the next day and throughout
this whole period the temperature has
risen
okay so when i take my observation here
say what was the minimum temperature in
the last 24 hours
it was over here
so when i take my observations in the
morning i tend to count a particularly
cold morning twice
if i'm the opposite and rather do it
when i come home from work i have the
opposite problem i now take my
observation at the time of day and
whoops looks like mac and pc got messed
up these were supposedly lined up
i take my observation at the time when
the temperature is the warmest so if i
came and i looked at this period of time
this would be my max not that
and then if i came the next day at 5 00
pm i would be counting that max twice so
the same type of thing but but in the
afternoon
so the morning observers tend to have a
cold bias the afternoon observers tend
to have a warm bias
and this wouldn't be a problem if
observers were random
but there has been a systematic shift
through time to take morning
observations so there's been an
artificial cooling in the climate record
due to that but really this adjustment
is pretty easy to figure out and it's a
pretty robust adjustment knowing what
the observation time was
so let's look at this this is some
trends in the hcn
but basically how does what is the
difference as we add each of these
adjustments so the green line is just if
we fill in missing data and it's
nothing really there to write home about
the red line is the instrument
adjustment so this is when we shifted
from a cotton region shelter to an mmts
in the mid 80s and as you can see that
that caused a very slight warm bias to
the record
the record warmed or our adjustment had
to be toward warming okay i said that
backwards the bias is actually cooling
and this is the adjustment that we need
if we look at the change in observation
time again a systematic shift to morning
observations is a cooling so our
adjustment we have to add warming to the
record and there you can see the
magnitude of this is on the order of
degrees f unfortunately but about a
third of a degree apparently
the station moves again
the adjustment is towards warming and
the reason for this is through time
there's been a systematic shift in
having stations in the center of the
city and then moving them out to an
airport location so baltimore might be a
good example where the station used to
be in the courthouse in the center of
baltimore and it got moved out to the
airport okay that in this case that's a
big enough move that it counts as two
stations but that gives you the general
flavor of these moves so there's a
there's a
cooling or actually the ithaca example
is a good example of that another
systematic shift was from rooftop
locations to ground locations so
there again a cooling in the record that
has to be adjusted
urbanization of course has the opposite
effect and here this population
adjustment is about a tenth of a degree
fahrenheit so really the biggest the
biggest difference there is the
observation time in the station moves
which together are about a half degree
fahrenheit um chris
i don't quite understand if you have a
maximum minimum thermometer either
automatic or
one that you can read the minimum
temperature off it doesn't matter when
the temperature is taken isn't it um so
what's this bias thing i don't quite it
does because they're not electronic
thermometers like a data logger where
you know what everything is at every
hour or every minute of the day so
basically the best analogy i can give to
the the liquid and glass thermometers
and they continue that in the electronic
thermometers it's like a fever
thermometer so you know you take your
temperature with a fever thermometer if
it's 103 it's you know you pull it out
of your mouth it's 103 and it stays at
103 until you shake it down okay so
these thermometers work exactly the same
way it records the highest temperature
that has been recorded since you have
reset it nothing in between does that
make sense yeah but then why wouldn't
you go to something more automatic where
you would know the exact temperature at
a particular moment in time it doesn't
matter when you read it all right and
and the the whole reason there is is
primarily
the federal government is broke and and
devoid on technology are
working on antiquated technology but the
other reason too is you have this big
long record you know 100 year record of
doing it one way the current technology
of electronic thermometers when the
observer goes out to game farm road
there is a readout that basically says
what was the highest temperature that
was recorded in the last 24 hours and
what was the coolest and that's it okay
there have been moves and we'll see to
get away from that in in the today this
keep in mind this is my
um i forget what it was times past
um the other thing is the u.s
temperature record from measurements
like this very much mirrors the national
uh the global record so if we see the
u.s record kind of a flat period in
through the 40s excuse me a rise from
the 1900s to about the 1940s a decrease
to about the 1970s increase we see the
same type of thing i have a different
scale here but here's my rise from the
1900s to about 1940 i kind of decrease
or flat period in through the 70s and
then my rise so really the u.s record is
a good match to the global record in
looking at these observed temperatures
all right the present
finally last five years or so
the noaa said hey we need to do
something to really monitor climate
change we need a network that really
does this and they've instituted what is
called the climatological reference
network
this is about 100 stations across the
u.s given by the
yellow dots one up here in canada
the layout of these dots was done very
scientifically we were involved in some
of the work to say what is the minimum
stations we can put out in the u.s to
get a good measure of what the
temperature trend has been okay so a lot
of actually the sighting of these
stations the spacing between these
stations is scientifically based
um
a crn station looks like that those are
the two in new york there's one out at
the animal science facility in hartford
and there's one down in millbrook okay
um actually the the climate center was
involved in sighting these stations and
it was a real bear particularly in the
northeast because one of the
requirements of these stations and there
was a whole review process is that the
area around the station
could not be expected to change
for 50 years
so we wanted to have game farm road be
one of these stations but when we went
you know one of the review processes was
look at okay what is cornell's plans for
expansion that's the way they planned on
expanding so that automatically mix that
so we were able to do that out in
hartford and this was really hard in the
northeast because number one it couldn't
be on private land it always had to be
on publicly so we had actually a nice
facility out anybody by the venture arm
at george junior i thought that would be
a great location for a site but
georgia university and private land is
publicly i mean it's it's privately held
land so that that got nicked so really
hard especially in the northeast
to site these stations but anyway
rain gates in there electronic sensors
there there's actually three redundant
sensors all looking at the same thing
actually within this
measuring solar radiation measuring wind
there are some things to see if things
are out of whack between the sensors so
they really did this upright to really
monitor climate into the future
and this is like five-minute data chris
so now we don't have this problem
um
and really increasingly a lot of the
indians
um
the criteria for citing these
yes they did basically they
you know a lot of argument of where you
put something along the coast right um
but as as long as the coast reflected
that trend in the temperature or needed
to to you know those stations were
looked at and how much did that affect
the u.s trend there was some sighting
there but most of them are actually even
away from large bodies of water rather
than criteria
um now increasingly now our observations
globally us are coming from a remotely
sense platform so we have a nice
satellite record going back from the end
of the 70s and really what i'm trying to
show here is the blue is surface
observations and a number of different
satellite platforms and here the trends
that you can make them out are a little
bit different that the slope is
different but yet the same type of an
increase
and just because there's satellites
these same types of problems that creep
into station data also creep in the
satellite the satellite orbits degrade
through time and that has to be adjusted
for um you know changes in atmospheric
moisture might affect the satellite
record so just because it's coming from
a satellite doesn't mean it's devoid of
these types of of things that go on in
the surface and increasingly for for
rainfall
radar is becoming a platform for those
um also a lot of our information and
this is really kind of my transition in
going from global circulation models to
observations
a lot of our observations is we use a
data set that's called the re-analysis
in the best way to describe a
re-analysis is it takes all kinds
basically data from any number of
platforms radiosondes weather balloons
aircraft surface observations
satellite how clouds are moving to get
an idea of the wind and these are the
data that go into um initializing
weather forecast models right so if i
have a gridded model to predict
tomorrow's weather i need to give it its
initial conditions
and these are the types of data that go
into that okay so what has been done is
going back
uh 30 or even in some cases 50 years to
take the observations that go into
initializing these forecasts put them
through a standardized routine so the
routine doesn't change through time okay
and then come up with a gridded data set
that blends all of these platforms
together so it's giving me things like
precipitation it's giving me things like
surface temperature but it's also giving
me things like wind speed and pressures
and heights and where the highs and lows
are okay much like a global circulation
model does so this
re-analysis data set sort of is going to
or it does provide a benchmark to global
circulation models and i'll show that in
some of my later slides
um all right so the future
um so really what is a climate model
getting to the
to the title of my talk you know like if
i can't get the weather right tomorrow
how do i get the climate right in 100
years so really in a climate model we
have to take this whole big climate
system the atmosphere the sun the
volcanoes the oceans the ice the
greenhouse gases the clouds you know the
agriculture and the land surface and
basically turn that into a model
so even though that's a nice picture
whoops
there it comes now basically i'm taking
all of that
and turning it into a lot of computer
okay so basically that is the
crux of the climate model i'm not we're
not going to go through a couple
equations but not too many
um
all right
all right what do i want to say
why do i have lava lamps because i think
again it's just an analogy i was trying
to think i think anybody can say oh if i
turn on the lava lamp
what's going to happen to the lava
it's going to rise in the land okay so
that's the basic physics of what's going
on i'm heating the lava from from the
bottom and it's rising okay but if i
asked a different question you know how
big is each blob of lava as it rises you
know or predict you know
when this guy rises the next one rises
how big is it's going to be nobody's
going to know that's more like the
weather or an example i usually do i
don't have it if i drop the piece of
paper okay i asked you what was if i
asked you to model what was going to
happen to the paper if i let go you'd
all say it's going to fall to the floor
right that's cool that's the climate
okay if i ask you where it was going to
land every time i drop it it's going to
land someplace difference and that's
just the chaos and then it's going to be
somewhere different and nobody's going
to be able to do that that's the weapon
so again here in the climate my example
is yes we're looking at if we add
greenhouse gases what is the overall
trend going to do
but really what we don't expect the
model to get are these inter-annual
variations
the model doesn't know you know the
model might replicate el nino
but the model has no idea in what year
an el nino is going to occur so maybe in
a hundred years the model will get it
right and there'll be an el nino
you know
every seven years or at the at the
historical rate of el ninos but if it's
going to it's not going to occur
you know you can't look at the model and
say oh the model is predicting an el
nino in 2016 you can't expect that to
happen so you won't see where i'm trying
to get at so you know we're getting the
overall trend but the timing of these
types of swiggles is not right or we
can't expect it to be right a good
example of that is the last several
years over the last 10 years we've
actually if you look at a trend it's
been cooling or flat people will say oh
climate change is over we'll know that
that cooling part is we're in one of
these valleys
and eventually will come out
so the model is trying to get the
overall trend the gross aspects of
things it can't be expected to get heavy
with
okay
models are gridded
basically the whole globe is divided
into a number of grid boxes kind of on
you know resolution changes with time
pretty much state of the art now it's
maybe 100 kilometers on the side a
degree by a degree maybe is a is a good
size global circulation model
grid boxes go up into the atmosphere
grid boxes go down into the ocean but
the idea is you know each of these grid
boxes is a node in the model so there's
one value for each of these grid boxes
one value for temperature one value for
elevation you name it
all of the models and there are a number
of different climate models out there
any number of climate groups has their
own model
but yet all of these models share pretty
much a common set of core physical
equations okay they need to conserve
momentum they need to service in a
special case momentum in the verticals
through the hydrostatic equation they
need to conserve mass they need to
conserve the energy and the equation of
state needs to apply to the atmosphere
so at the crux of all these models this
is it these are you know these are the
core
equations and we won't go into those too
much
but really where the art
comes into state of the art and climate
model is through how things are
parameterized how do we take care of
things that occur at grits at a scale
that is smaller than the grid scale of
the model
so here a good example and maybe not a
good example i couldn't get a good
picture here is is clouds okay you know
where clouds really matter is that the
scale of the individual drops
if i look at a cloud or you know you sit
in on my cloud physics class but whether
a cloud is going to reflect solar
radiation or allow solar radiation to
pass through or absorb long wave
radiation really depends on what are the
sizes of the drops and the sizes of the
drops are like nanometers okay we're
small scale here and uh basically what
is the density of those drops so these
are things that are on many orders of
magnitude smaller scale than the model
is able to to take into account keep in
mind we have about a degree by a degree
box and we have to say it's cloudy or
it's not soft okay so those types of
things need to be parameterized into the
model and again kind of simple things if
the relative humidity in the model over
the grid box reaches a certain level
it's cloudy or this cloud has this
albedo in it based on that so there are
a number of ways to do it and that's how
one model may differ from another so
that's why my answer might come out to
be different than somebody else's so we
have a spread of solutions going into
the future mainly due to how these are
parameterized
um and again there's been a whole
evolution through time not only this
these f-a-r-s-a-r-t-a-r are the ipcc
reports so that's the first assessment
report the second um
the fourth finally i guess they needed
to do something because the fourth and
the fifth were both gonna be far but
anyway you can see the size of the grid
boxes are going from about about 500
kilometers on the side
in the first assessment report to about
100 kilometers on the side now
the way things are parameterized in the
models has changed dramatically you know
in the 70s there were no clouds you know
if there was enough water in the
atmosphere it rained out and that was it
no clouds um you know even here in the
70s there was no ocean there was just a
lot of water and water was allowed to
evaporate but there was no current there
was no deep circulation in the ocean all
the ocean was was a source of water
vapor for the atmosphere
and then finally as we get
into the recent period of time i mean we
got a really sophisticated model we have
an ocean with a circulation deep
circulation surface circulation
atmosphere chemistry is starting to be
modeled
the vegetation at the surface starts to
interact and is dynamic not just static
through time so a whole evolution in how
these models have
come about and primarily uh the thing
that's that's going on here is an
increase in computing power
really uh right on through this the
models have been pushing the available
computer power
all right
so
kind of going back to how well my models
are doing if you remember the
observations and these are the global
observations we have this period of time
from 1900 to 1920 where the temperature
rises a cooling in through the 40s
through the 70s and then the rise again
so it have kind of this kind of
zigzag pattern
let's see what happens when we try to
model
so one of the nice things about climate
model
is we can play games with the climate
model we can we can in some ways play
god we can add greenhouse gases we can
take away greenhouse gases we can make
volcanoes erupt we cannot make volcanoes
erupt we can make the sun brighter we
can make the sun dimmer we can do all of
these things and see how that impacts
what the object of the model is so
here's an example again of
my zigzag of temperature
and a climate model that is run with the
only change through this period of time
is the change in the greenhouse gases so
the greenhouse gases in the model are
changed according to what has been
observed
and as we can see this red line is the
model
it really doesn't match very well with
the observed pattern that i have and
through here
you know the trend is about right
they're offset missus is cooling totally
and not really getting this right over
here not a good match
do the same thing in this case keep the
greenhouse gases constant
and the only thing change in the model
is the change in the natural forces and
here basically volcanic eruptions and
changes in the solar intensity
and if we look at that well if you
notice the model here
again in the red kind of matches a
little bit better here
starts to match a little bit better here
and then we have this rise
and then finally
we put it all together okay
have the observations in black and kind
of my general trends in blue to model in
red
and we see that the model at least in my
in my view matches the observations
fairly well we're able to capture this
warming in the early part of the record
that probably isn't has nothing to do or
very little to do with greenhouse gases
but has everything to do with the sun
being brighter and there being a lack of
volcanic eruptions
we get this cooling
fairly well in through here
50s what's going on there sulfate
aerosols okay burning dirty coal acid
rain okay
basically the aerosols that we emit when
we burn coal are reflective so they
reduce the amount of incoming solar
radiation and actually on this global
scale we have a cooling
and then as we get into the 70s this is
the
large increase in greenhouse gases very
little to do with natural variations in
this period of time and also at a time
when we've been cleaning up the coals
sulfate air assaults are becoming less
and less and less in most parts of the
world not all parts
so again my example here of a climate of
climate model doing a pretty good job of
of matching the observations really
throughout this whole 100-plus year
period of time
okay
and then finally
how do we get these big
large-scale grid boxes
to come down to a local level
how do we say okay this box here that's
the size of new york or almost the size
of new york that has one temperature
value one everything how do we start to
make some
inferences on how climate change will
impact
say the wine industry perhaps water
resources in the new york city watershed
things that happen on a small scale we
don't care about what's going on
globally or even new york size we need
to bring these data down to
down to a different level
and just as an example of what i mean
this is the united states and this is
the elevation of the united states as
seen by climate model
so you do see the rocky mountains here
and kind of the white but they're no
more than a little hump a little bump on
the map
but if we go down to the scale we really
need we want the mountains to look like
that that's the thing that's driving the
snowpack in the west and water resources
in the west not this little
pump in the map
so these types of features start to
become very very important when we want
to look at local scale impacts or even
regional scale impacts
so the way we get from one to another is
through a process called downscale and
really here it's an idea of resolving
the mismatch of the scales
show some examples that can be done
statistically
or it can be done dynamically so
basically using a finer scale model to
do the downscale
both of these have their origins in
weather prediction in the current state
of the art is one is no better than the
other they both have their pros and cons
in the end
either one of these is an acceptable
method we've been doing a lot of work
recently in the climate project that
dave and jonathan have been involved
with in us over in bradfield really
looking at statistical downscaling but
uh we've been doing some dynamical
downscaling too for things like lake
effect snow that kind of lends itself to
that application
just to give you an idea of how this
works in weather forecasting okay
this is the results from last week of
the eas weather forecasting contest
and a bunch of these are students but
basically what i wanted to show is the
best forecast here is basically through
a statistical downscaling
okay so it's a totally statistical
forecast this has no no person is
involved okay it comes right off the
computer and that's actually doing quite
well
it's beating me
okay
um
and that's a consensus so this is a
number of these different statistical
approaches here's a particular
statistical approach and again it's
doing fairly well
um brian is our computer guru and he
runs the dynamical model basically takes
the forecast right from the model again
the models
so this idea of down scaling from a
model to the game farm road weather
station
now it's it's we see it in action
in weather forecasts and my argument
here is either i'm doing pretty poorly
or it does it it's doing pretty well in
this case for the
semester notice where my sake is if
anybody knows
who's your humanoid
uh i'm one of the one of the undergrads
so
um
anyway um you know so if we look at
statistical downscaling first
really the biggest pro is it's
computationally inexpensive it's easy to
do or relatively easy to do
um we can tailor it
to specific variables we can look at
some exotic things things that aren't
even in the climate models storm surges
air quality perhaps
can be made site specific
but the downsides is you know the
biggest downside perhaps
is it's not describing the physical
process so we're making a big leap of
faith that whatever we're basing our
statistics on
isn't changing in the future right so
we're saying okay whatever the
relationship we're looking at today or
basing our model on today is going to
hold in the future
and that may or may not be a good
assumption
the simplest way to do this is just to
say okay
i use this in providence basically if i
want to look at providence annual precip
and i look at the gcm grid that
encompasses
providence and i strike a regression
and it's not a one-to-one relationship
if it were perfect but it's somewhere
off of the one-to-one line and i can use
that as my downside not very
not very uh
i don't want to say too much about that
still a way to do it
um looking at some of the more common
ways that are doing this in the new york
assessment again that dave and jonathan
and some others in the room have been
involved with
they use what's called a delta method
and basically here we have an observed
distribution of temperature
in this case our observed period is from
70 to 2000.
and we have what the model says
is the observed distribution of
temperature for that particular point
in the same period of time
and they don't match up
okay and then we have what the model is
saying the temperature is at some point
time in the future
and the delta becomes the model present
minus the model future so this blue area
there
and then that delta is applied back to
the data so in other words here are my
daily observations from say of
temperature from say rochester
from 1970 and to each day all i do is
add this delta so if this delta were 5
degrees each observation here gets
inflated by five degrees again a fairly
simple method of doing it
the biggest drawback in my mind is the
variability of the climate never changes
if it was cold on this day
relatively cold on this day in 1970 it's
going to be relatively cold on that day
and
in the future model just five degrees
warmer so the same progression of
temperature changes stays
it just gets translated upward
um
some more sophisticated methods actually
look at the whole distribution of
temperature and allows delta to change
not
defines delta not just at the median or
the average but across the whole
distribution so this would be my example
here of perhaps in the green and
observed here we have a cumulative
distribution function on percentage of
observations here in green and how does
the delta change at each of these nodes
and maybe the model is cooler at the
very low end and maybe it's higher at
the very high end and maybe there's a
large difference in the middle so each
of these are taking into account and
therefore we can start to adjust days
differently depending on how hot or cold
they are
i'm going to skip the next one
another way to do this
is to look at a greater suite of
predictors to use all this information
that the climate models give us things
like you know what is the 500 millibar
height i think of a weather map how what
are the winds doing the law so use all
this whole you know if you think of if i
ask you
um
you know if i told you
from the model it was going to be cloudy
today and there was going to be a trough
over new york you know would you say
even basic weather would you say it's
going to be a hot day or a warm day
let's try that again a hot day or a cold
day a cool day right a trough is
generally cool clouds we don't have any
sun so that type of broad scale
information kind of gets some some
information
so where do i want to go with that
here's an example of downscaling using
this for snowpack
okay so this is some work that we've
done
where lots of lines here probably not
the best graph to show
on the screen the black line is the
historical
snow depth
at
wanakina ranger station in the
adirondacks okay
the blue line
is basically a climate model that we
have downscaled to that particular
location
so i would argue that in my blue line
we're doing pretty good in getting the
maximum
average snow depth this over a period of
time so in any average year you would
expect there to be at least 20 inches of
snow on the ground
pretty much getting the timing fairly
good in the beginning in the end we're
losing our snowpack at least the similar
rate our timing's off by a few by about
a week or two but we basically replicate
this fairly well in the downscale
the purple the mustard and the red are
the model run on this station
through
into the future so we've downscaled the
data from the gcm for the 20s the 50s
and the 80s we see in the in the 20s the
purple line
we reduce our snowpack a little bit not
much
and we kind of shorten our snow season
there but it's really not until the 50s
and the 80s that we really see dramatic
increases in the snow depth of this
station based on this downscaling
basically going from on average
20 inches to on average about four
inches of snow at this adirondack
location
also notice not too much change in
what's going on at the beginning of the
season when we start to accumulate snow
but a dramatic change at the end of the
season for when we lose the snowpack
basically from mid mid may to actually
early april and when the snowpack comes
out so again a technique that can be
used
for downscaling
dynamical downscaling we're using
basically a model in a model
so it's keeping the physics but it's
very computationally expensive
so as an example
if i wanted to focus in on the us
what i would do is have a small area
just over the u.s float kind of cut it
out like a patchwork quilt
and basically
the world is going to end at these
boundaries
but in each of the boundaries what's
going to be fed in are conditions from
the global circulation model
so those global grids basically are
feeding what's going on in this in this
inner model and in this inner model we
can start to get the resolution down to
the things that might resolve the
adirondacks and the lakes and things
along those lines
and as an example
kind of is showing a number of different
approaches
this is
obviously the northeast
these are data out of the northeast
climate impacts assessment by
heyho eddal and the ed al is dave wolf
and i was involved with that and a
number of other people at cornell so
this is a report that preceded the
climate report and we're looking at uh
precipitation here i believe in this
graphic
and in in panel e
these are the stations and basically the
the blues are showing different levels
of precipitation
given by the
scale h
on the other hand
are is the precipitation from a global
circulation model so that's why we have
these big patches each of these boxes is
one of the grids from the model
the f is if we down scale this with a
dynamical model okay so feed this
information into a finer scale model you
can get an idea of what the grid size is
from these boxes and you can see we
start to pick up more of the detail you
can see the adirondacks and their effect
toward higher precipitation you can see
some of that down in the catskills as
well you can see some of the mountains
or graphic precipitation coming out in
new england
and then finally
in this panel here this is a
statistically downscaled simulation of
the same data so all of these are
showing the same thing stations global
model dynamically downscaled
statistically downscaled and here this
is downscaled to about an eighth of a
degree resolution better than this and
again kind of picking up the adirondacks
catskills actually our highest rainfall
in new york
is right around here in the new york
city watershed that comes out very
nicely
up and down the mountains of
vermont
and i think
i will open it up for some questions
here
in the last slide that you had
so in g it looks like connecticut gets a
lot more rain
um but but it doesn't
you know in the large model in h and
then the other one in f so why
you know it seems like it's fairly
consistent with new york but all of a
sudden connecticut but not
in new jersey you know and so that's
just
aspect of the model i guess again aspect
of the model um
basically probably some coastal
influences there if you actually look if
we actually looked at the observations
of sport as sparse as they are
um you know basically you have this
larger connecticut and the observations
look a lot like most of new york except
except the high peaks of the adirondacks
so in this case this statistical method
does make a little bit more sense that
way rather than this keeping in mind i'm
cheating a little bit there because
these observations are driving the
statistics
they're not driving the dynamical model
here in this case
and again an example of this being used
in real time if you watch again going
going from climate to weather if if you
watch any of the local weather you know
weather casts on tv where they kind of
have their own they basically are
running their own mini model especially
now that it's getting the lake effect
season you know a big national forecast
model that's not going to get the lake
effect but these smaller models that can
resolve the lake and resolve the
temperatures of lake will get that so
that's what's being used on this small
scale
by the tv meteorologists and actually
the weather service offices around new
york
so that that type of information is
there in
none of the global circulation models is
are the great lakes included or i take
that back one or two so if we're looking
at something like grey lakes that is
just something that is falling through
the cracks in these models and then even
as we get down to the smaller scale if
we're looking at things like what might
be going on in the finger lengths
it's in most of the finest scale models
they're you know the finger lights
themselves are one grid box so it's
really tough even there to look at that
type of effect so we really have a scale
effecting going here now if we wanted to
look at what's going to be going on
right in the lakes um we have to
basically take the models that are out
there and actually increase the
resolution to get the lakes because the
lakes are just
just
just too small to be resolved if they
were a little bit bigger they would be
nicely in there but
their
current size doesn't match up with
the greeting in these models
yeah i'm not sure how to ask this
actually but if you go backwards in this
in this process you're talking about
this an amazing increase in computing
power needs to do the global climate
model
yet most people
yeah okay that's interesting but i want
to know what with 100 certainly what the
weather is going to be a week from today
because i've got a wedding to go to with
that
right so is the computing power that
we're getting for the global climate
model uh
filtering down to these more local and
shorter term situations
it is to a certain degree but i mean the
bad news is you're never going to get
100 accuracy because it's just the the
chaos in the system now you can have as
much computing power as you want but the
solutions to the equations that you need
to solve and in the real world are in
some cases you know they have multiple
solutions or you know you have you know
the idea of a butterfly flapping its
wings and you go off in another
direction you're never going to have the
observations at a at a fine enough
density to resolve all of that to get it
so you get down to a level it's it's not
so much the computing power but the
opposite you know you need to have the
observations to
you know garbage in garbage out if you
don't have the observations at the scale
but things are happening you're not
going to be able to initialize the model
at those scales and even there the
equations can go awry with a with a
small tweak
where what is done both in the weather
scale and also the climate scale is
using what are called ensembles
so in other words i can and that's where
the computing power comes in i can take
my initialization of the model and tweak
it a little bit to say i'm not exactly
sure what the state of the atmosphere
looks like right now so i'm going to say
up it could look like this it could look
like that it could look like something
else and in each of those cases i'm
going to use that as an initial
condition to my model
and then as i modeled it into the future
the idea is if you know the initial
state makes a big difference the models
are going to diverge and then i can say
chris flip a coin for your wedding but
if the if the if the divergent you know
if the models are close together that
gives you some increase in certainty in
your forecast so i mean a lot i know i
see marty in the back a lot of times
when when when we do the turf call you
know i'll say i don't have any
confidence in what's going to happen a
week from now and then some weeks i say
yeah it looks pretty good it's going to
be hot it's going to be dry and kind of
what we're looking at there is you know
are these ensembles going off in
different directions or are they all
converging on the same solution
do the same thing with the climate model
and there you can not so much tweak the
initial conditions but one what's done
there is really the thing that's driving
the differences there are how the models
are parameterized so are clouds going to
make a big difference and is this guy
doing the clouds better than somebody
else so an ensemble of climate models
tends to be basically just different
models or slightly different models to
see how that progresses out so
you know you never see you're never
going to see in 2100 that this is what
the temperature is going to be it's
going to be a range of temperatures to
give the idea of uncertainty can you
have a question yeah with respect to the
duration of the snowpack particularly
higher latitude do the models take into
consideration albedo changes
um
yes and no
um i guess i'll ask you a question which
models are we talking about
so
at the global scale yes
um and these dynamical models yes so if
you know in a dynamic model if it's you
know even if we're at a small
one kilometer two kilometer grid if it's
snowing more
um yes i mean that is clearly
one of the main things that will be
driving those models is what is the
albedo and that will be related to the
snowpack when we get into a statistical
model you know there is no there isn't
that give and take there in that case
it's basically
at the large scale this is what it's
predicting and albedo is you know part
of that
um
and it goes from there does that answer
the question yeah more or less uh
with respect to you know discussions
about foreign station on a large global
scale um
apparently albedo is
one consideration sure
right and that's i mean
yes that's clearly something that's
that's used in the models i mean
actually we do in my climate change
class we read a paper where they have
they they
at far estate a large part of canada and
the idea is that well that should draw
down co2 and it should be a good thing
for climate change but in the end what
it does is you're taking you know
they're doing this on the prairies that
are normally snow covered in the winter
so what you're doing is taking wind snow
cover and putting coniferous forest
which has is absorbing a lot of
radiation so basically the radiation
effect absorbing that radiation equals
the same amount of warming that you get
you know by removing the greenhouse so
it's a balance in the end
due to that so you know that is one of
the neat things about the models that
you can you can do those exercises and
do those thought experiments
clearly when the models are run
for these big ipcc reports
the runs take
years to run so the runs for the current
the next ipcc report
are actually
being ginned up now
a lot of the runs for these ice the next
round of ipcc reports will be done at
in not the entire globe but in a large
portion of the globe at a very fine
resolution it will almost be like not
dynamically down scaling but actually
running the global models that select
locations at a very very fine scale the
usb
so it's going to be a very different you
know as the models increase we'll see a
very different flavor to the kind of
ipcc reports that'll come out in the in
the future it'll be much more down to a
little bit regional level
you you showed us why uh you can make
much better predictions on climate than
a weather forecast
but when you start downscaling as you
describe
do you introduce
a lot of noise in that manner so that
the predictions you're making for let's
say ithaca versus syracuse become
almost the same kind of noise as your
weather forecasting knows
yes and no i mean what i want to say is
where it doesn't become the noise
is if you're representing a key process
if you're dying if you're dynamically
downscaling okay and let's use the lakes
as an example
so let's say i care about like how lake
effect snow is going to change or even
in the forecast i care about whether
there's going to be lake effect snow
the fact that i'm putting those lakes in
there and allowing you know physically
modeling that process
i'm getting a lot of signal there
if we're going
if we're taking the lakes out and just
saying okay how is the temperature going
to vary between maybe not i'll not pick
on syracuse it's binghamton so to speak
so there really it's just noise there's
not a big driving physical mechanism
that would make that change like would
be in lake effect my answer was going to
be yes
that makes sense
this is a real local application
question okay
i think the journal gets information on
weather
i believe their forecasts come from a
private forecasting company in state
college pennsylvania
they don't get it from us
we a long time ago we used to i mean
same type of thing when i was at rutgers
many moons ago
meteorology department there used to
forecast local paper but as
the media markets have gotten more uh
global and national olympic companies
involved going through these companies
there is no
the only thing that might come that does
come in the journal is the observations
so
that's unfortunate
yeah it's on the you portal too yeah so
what on the cornell site okay yeah
all right
i think you got a question question from
geneva go ahead
yeah i've heard cases where there's uh
suggestions that the night temperatures
will warm more than day temperatures
in the future uh can you talk about
about that is that is that always going
to be the case or and what what's the
basis of that
um
that is definitely true in the
observations any of the models do show a
warming of of nighttime temperatures
relative to daytime temperatures
um
you know it's not what it is not
is the fact you know we're always
radiating energy so it's not the fact
that you know at night time we're not
getting any sunlight so we're just
radiating energy um really there it is a
combination most of the the change in
nighttime temperature i believe has to
do actually with more land use change
and things like that where um you know
urbanization and and and
things along those lines even just
buildings and things like that have a
higher heat capacity so the heat is
being stored more at the day and then
being given off at night
that answer your question alan
yeah thanks
so tomorrow is the election
i've heard
quite a few uh republican politicians
the last couple weeks saying that this
whole thing is just a liberal hoax to
you know
get more
votes or
do you
do you think the modeling
will ever reach a level or there is
some number of data points or some
margin of error that we will get to that
will
convince skeptics that this is really
happening
no
i mean
and i'm not saying that
i am a climatologist
uh the reason that i'm saying that is
there'll always be uncertainty i mean
there always isn't
and um i think it's not an issue of
whether the science is correct or
accurate or not um in my in my opinion
it's it's an issue of what do we have to
do to correct the problem and the
solution to the problem
is
not appealing um it will require drastic
changes in the way we do business and
operate society and things like that and
and that's the thing that in my mind
drives the politics
and the sides of things and you know
where it becomes tough is you know it is
hard to say and if you know
if i'm along the coast and i'm new york
city and i'm pretty darn you know there
you know sea level rise
the error bars there are getting smaller
and smaller smaller you have a big
problem that's a lot of money you know i
i need to solve that problem if i'm here
in upstate new york talking to neil in
minnesota
you know
maybe a few degrees of warming you know
there's opportunities so there's going
to be winners and losers so you have
that that part of thing too but if we're
looking collectively as a globe
uh clearly the problem is there the
solution to the problem of global
warming is in my mind also the solution
to a lot of the other world's problems
and you know that whole thing should be
packaged together and coming up with
solutions so does that take home voting
perhaps we should end it there
let's thank art again
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu